Afghanistan has a new president the
Electoral Commission has officially put
an end two months of acrimony this one
was buckling papa the Independent
Election Commission declares his
Excellency dr. Muhammad Ashraf Ghani
president of the Islamic Republic of
Afghanistan this is the conclusion of
the electoral process but the Commission
won't say how many votes garni received
and it conceded the vote was marred by
irregularities hours earlier the former
rivals concluded a political partnership
garni here on the right and Abdullah
Abdullah have agreed to a government of
national unity they signed the pact at
carpals presidential palace under the
arrangement Abdullah will become
Afghanistan's chief executive that means
he'll be in charge of running the
country day to day and all senior
government posts will be divided between
the two men's supporters residents in
Kabul watched a live broadcast of the
signing their divided about this deal
aughh sorrow is awesome I'm satisfied
with this news and the Afghan people are
happy about the signing of this
agreement today we are unhappy with
these elections because they brought us
trouble and pushed our country into
crisis the pact follows months of
protest over the outcome of June's
runoff presidential election the
Electoral Commission said garni one
Abdullah charged that he lost due to
fraud Ghani and Abdullah biggest
challenge will be to maintain security
once NATO completes its withdrawal of
combat forces scheduled for the end of
the year